J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK, so
we're ready for a new
phase here, to talk about
spectroscopy, the interaction
of light with matter and what it
can
tell us about molecules.
We'll talk today about
electronic and infrared
spectroscopy, and in particular,
with infrared
spectroscopy, about normal modes
and the mixing and
independence of vibrations.
So the purposes we use
spectroscopy for are to
determine structure and to study
dynamics.
So we use electronic
spectroscopy that's visible and
UV, where it's motion of
electrons that's being excited
by the light.
Or vibrational, where it's
motion of the nuclei, the
atoms, being excited by the
light.
Or NMR, where it's a magnetic
interaction with
light that's involved.
Spectroscopy comes from the word
specter.
In 1605 it was used, according
to the Oxford English
Dictionary.
to be straunge sights, visions
and apparitions, so that's
like the specters of ghosts,
right?
Or Newton used it in the 1670s
to be Sunbeams...
passing through
a glass prism...
exhibited there a spectrum of
diverse colors... so this
kind of ghost. So that's where
the word comes from.
Now Atom in a Box, which we
used last semester and it's
shown over on this screen, can
be used to
show a number of things.
It can show spectral transitions
for the H atom.
Let's get this here.
And if you click spectrum here,
you get--
where is it now?
I think it's off the screen.
I enlarged things here.
But anyhow, it gives you what
the spectral transitions are,
what energies are involved in
going from one-- oh, I think
it's because I didn't get
simplified at work here.
What's going on?
Why isn't it simplifying?
My guess is because I blew this
up to be on the screen.
It's not showing.
Anyhow, we've done that before
and seen that you can
see the energy levels of
different things, different
atomic levels and the wavelength
that's involved.
We can see the static shift in
electron density, from if
mixing 2s with 2p orbitals.
Maybe I'm going to have to bring
this back down again,
and see if it works now.
I don't know why it's not
working.
Well, fortunately, the most
important stuff I'm going to
have is A, displaying there, and
B, also on the PowerPoint,
so you can do this on your own
time.
OK, you can see the shift, as we
saw last semester, from
mixing 2s with 2p.
Remember, that'll shift the
electrons from one side to the
other of the nucleus, depending
on the hybridization.
We can see the oscillation of
electron density that comes
from mixing orbitals with
different energy, and that's
what's involved here.
You'll notice over here, we've
got a mixture of the 1s with a
2p orbital.
What we showed before was fixed
in time, and it would
shift it up or down.
But if you look at it as time
goes on, you see that it
actually goes back and forth
between being down and being
up, being down and being up.
So the electrons, when you mix
1s and 2p, oscillate up and
down in time.
And that's because of a change
in relative phase with time.
You add s with p, and then
subtract s with p, and it goes
one way and then the other.
And I'm going to illustrate
that.
This is a feature of
time-dependent quantum
mechanics, where the phase of
the wave function changes at a
rate proportional to its energy.
And I'll go through this just a
little
bit on the next slide.
We're not going to spend too
much time on it, because it's
not really the business of this
class.
But it's so neat that I thought
you'd like
to know about it.
But anyhow, when you have the
electron shifting up and down
like that, it's like an antenna.
It gives off light.
In fact, it can absorb light,
too.
Antennas can either transmit or
receive.
So that's what allows electrons
in atoms to interact
with light as an oscillating
dipole.
You can also do breathing by
mixing 1s with 2s, but that
doesn't interact with light,
because it
doesn't generate a dipole.
And I'm going to illustrate
that.
So here's 1s, mixing
1s and 2p.
So as we see here, if 2p is
both up and down, but with
opposite phases, 1s is a single
phase, a single sign.
If you add the two, it
reinforces above.
OK, and we've seen that before.
But if you make it time
dependent--
that's what's being shown over
there--
then what happens in time, is
that it goes up and down.
it's And the oscillation
frequency, how rapidly it goes
up and down, that is what color
of light would interact
with it, what frequency of
light, has to do with the
energy difference between
1s and 2p.
So here, this is just a
footnote.
You're not deeply responsible
for this, but I
wanted you to see it.
So I'll just read it to you.
A time-dependent wave function
looks just like the
psi's we've been talking about,
functions of position.
Except that it's also got
something to
do with time, obviously.
It's multiplied by e to the i
omega t.
And you know e to the ix is
cos x + i sin x.
Have you done that?
I think you may have seen that.
So you have a cosine and a sine
of omega t, one is real
and one is imaginary.
It's a complex number that
you're multiplying the wave
function by.
So i is a square root of -1.
Omega is the energy in frequency
units.
That's how rapidly things are
changing in time, because it's
cos omega t.
So as time increases, the cosine
goes up between plus
and minus one.
And how fast it goes up and down
depends on how big omega
is, because omega t is what
you're taking the cosine of.
So the higher frequency omega
is, the faster it'll go up and
down, the higher energy
omega is.
And now that's an interesting
question, because it depends
on what-- the magnitude of the
energy for any given system--
depends on where you define 0 to
be.
If you to define 0 to be
separated particles, that's
one energy.
If you define it to be the
ground state, that's a
different energy.
And this would suggest that the
rate of oscillation
depends on what you call 0.
That seems nuts, right?
It can't depend on you, what the
rate of oscillation is.
And the reason is, you don't
care what the rate of
oscillation is.
And I'll show you why.
Because when you square the wave
function to get the
probability density, at any
given time, you multiply psi
times e to the i omega t,
times psi to the e to the
-i omega t.
That's how you do squaring with
complex numbers, multiply
by the complex conjugate.
And that gives psi squared.
All the stuff about time cancels
out.
So you don't really care.
So why do you have it in there
in the first place?
If you're mixing two different
states that have different
energy, then they oscillate at
different frequencies.
So really, you don't care how
fast either one
is oscillating alone.
You only care what the
difference in frequencies is.
So now it doesn't depend on what
you call 0, because the
one state you're taking and the
other state you're taking
have the same difference,
whatever 0 is.
That's where you make a
difference.
So it says, when a problem
involves actually mixing two
states of different energy, one
considers a wave function
of the form, e to the i omega
1t, plus a different psi, the
other wave function, times e to
the I omega 2t.
Now, if omega 1 and omega 2
are different, this means that
the two spatial functions cycle
in and out of phase with
one another.
If at a certain time they add at
a time 1/2 divided by the
difference in frequency later,
they subtract.
So 1s + 2pz will become
1s - 2pz.
So if this is the energy here,
the oscillation frequency of
2pz, then 1s will have a lower
oscillation frequency, by that
energy difference between them.
And it'll look like that.
So here, they're in phase with
one another, the cosine part,
they're adding.
But in the middle there, they're
out of phase, and it's
subtracting.
And then it comes back into
phase again at the far right.
So as time goes along, it comes
s+p, s-p, s+p, s-p,
and the electrons go up
and down.
So if you mix these two
orbitals--
so an electric field that's
oscillating up and then down
and then up and then down favors
this at the first time,
then plus, then minus, then
plus, then minus.
So the light interacts with the
electrons and pushes them
up and down, mixing 1s with
2p.
Now, if you do that for a while,
and then turn the light
off, it may end up being in the
s-p, when it started
in the s-p, or vice versa.
So you can get an absorption, or
indeed, an
emission of light, the
interaction with light and
things, because of this time
dependence.
But again this is not really our
business, and you'll see
that later.
So this is the source of the
oscillation we observe, when
superimposing functions of
different n
using Atom in a Box, different
energies.
So that thing going up and down
over there.
And note, just as a footnote to
a footnote, this is
different from what we were
doing when we made hybrids.
We mixed s with p before.
Usually we were mixing 2s with
2p, which have very similar
energies, right?
But in those cases, we weren't
trying to mix two real states,
that's why I said actually up
there.
There we were just trying to get
in a reasonable form for a
wave function of some particular
energy.
But when light is involved, you
actually mix states of
different energies, so it's a
different situation.
So we've got this oscillation up
and down, which
interacts with light.
It can generate light.
It can absorb light.
Now, the 1s to 2p transition
is said to be allowed, because
it happens with light.
But there are other mixtures
that don't generate light.
For example, if you mix
1s with 2s.
If you add the two, it
reinforces where they're blue,
and subtracts when they're red.
That makes a big circle, a big
sphere.
But if you subtract them, make
the one on the left red and
add it to the other one, then
they'll reinforce in the
middle and cancel on the
outside, and it'll be inside.
So if you mix those two, you get
this dependence with time.
I think it's going to do it.
Whoops, I didn't wait long
enough.
But what happens, and you can do
it yourself, it goes [makes
expanding and contracting
sounds].
It's breathing.
But that's not separating the
average position of the
nucleus and the electron.
It's not going up and down to
make a vector, a light.
It's just expanding and
contracting.
So that symmetrical breathing
electron-density deformation
has no oscillator strength.
It doesn't interact with light's
magnetic field.
So that transition is said to be
forbidden.
You can't cause it to occur with
light.
Now, what does this have to do
with organic molecules and the
things we were just talking
about, which were polyenes.
You remember a bunch of bunch of
double bonds in a row.
Well, suppose you have C=X
double bond, and X is some
heteroatom, like oxygen or
nitrogen, it's something
that has an unshared pair of
electrons.
So it has n electrons.
But it also has a pi* orbital,
a vacant orbital.
Now, can you mix those two?
What would happen if you mixed
those two orbitals?
You could add them together, and
they'd reinforce in the
top-right and cancel on the
bottom-right.
And you get the electrons to
move up.
And if you changed the sign,
they'd move down, if you
subtracted one from the other.
So here's a way that light gets
a handle on the electrons
that are an unshared pair, and
can make them go into pi*,
by mixing the sigma,
unshared-pair electrons,
with pi*.
Now, that's neat, because as it
goes up and down you absorb
light, and the large energy gap
between the unshared pair
and pi* means that this
transition occurs
at very high frequency.
Because remember, the frequency
of cycling in and
out of phase is the difference
in the
energies of the two things.
So if they're fairly far apart,
it'll be a very high
frequency of light, not in the
visible.
So it's in the ultraviolet.
How could you make those two
orbitals closer in energy?
The unshared pair you couldn't
do much about, except maybe
changing one atom what
is involved,
oxygen, nitrogen, sulfur,
things like that.
How could you change the
energy of the
LUMO in the pi system?
Anybody got an idea?
So if you put more double bonds
conjugated with it--
remember, the LUMO comes down,
the HOMO comes up.
So you can bring it closer to
the energy of
the unshared pair.
If we put more and more double
bonds in there, then the LUMO
is going to look like this.
It approaches the energy of an
isolated p orbital, so the
light will get redder and redder
that interacts.
And this makes a lot of
differences as the pi*
approaches the energy of the 2p
orbital.
So for example, this molecule,
which has an unshared pair on
nitrogen here, which could mix
with pi* of this really
long conjugated system.
That's the imine of
retinaldehyde.
That's what's in rhodopsin.
That's the light sensitive stuff
in your eye.
So when light comes in, it
excites this transition, and
it triggers then to your brain
and so on, because the cis
isomer changes to the trans
isomer at this double bond.
And that's how you see.
Incidentally--
that compound, I just put this
in as another footnote: let's
not spend time on it-- but this
is the actual report of
Lindlar's catalyst. Remember,
the poisoned catalyst that'll
reduce triple bonds to double
bonds, but won't
reduce double bonds.
And he said it was in the
context
of vitamin A synthesis.
During work on the synthesis of
vitamin A, a palladium-lead
catalyst was developed, which
one could hydrogenate a triple
bond without attacking double
bonds already present.
But the things he was working on
we're things like this.
Really long conjugated things,
like b-carotenyne, which he
made, which had a triple bond in
the middle, as you see.
And then he could react it with
his special catalyst and
get the cis addition of two
hydrogens to give the
b-carotene.
And he says the hydrogens are
added in cis arrangement to
one another.
But then he goes on to say that
he could, with heated
and light he was able
quantitatively to convert the
cis isomer into the trans
isomer, which is what he
wanted to have for b-carotene.
OK, now notice, this was C40H56,
this big long thing.
And you know why it's that kind
of number, because it's
made up of these isoprene units
that we talked about in
the last quarter, polymerization
of isoprene to
give these natural products.
OK, that's just a footnote to
last semester, it's made from
isopentenyl pyrophosphate.
Now, retinal is the stuff that's
involved in making this
visual pigment.
And b-carotene is that, and
obviously, it's called
b-carotene because that's what
makes carrots that way.
And that's why you eat carrots
to make your eyes good, right?
Bugs Bunny has good vision
because of that.
Now, this related compound is
called isozeaxanthin.
And it turns out to be the stuff
that's in the feathers
of the scarlet tanager.
Now, what's weird about this,
it's what makes the scarlet
tanager yellow-green, right?
What's wrong with that?
It's supposed to be a scarlet
tanager.
But this is actually late in the
fall.
If you looked a little bit
earlier in the fall, the
Scarlet Tanager looks like this.
So it's got a little bit of red
in it.
But notice that this OH out on
the right, which has an
unshared pair that could go into
the pi system, that
oxygen is not part of the
pi system.
You can't generate any overlap
by that, because the oxygen is
not where the pi system is.
It's not conjugated.
The OH unshared pair is
isolated, so you can't do this
thing of taking an unshared pair
and putting it into the
LUMO, the pi LUMO.
But if you oxidize it to make
that, then you get it
conjugated, and that's the
scarlet tanager in the summer.
So it's exactly this changing of
unshared pairs into the pi
star orbital with a really long
conjugated chain that
gives this most vivid of our
birds' colors.
And these come in East Rock Park
about a month or month
and a half from now, so you can
go see them yourselves.
They knock your eyes out.
OK, so we're talking about
spectroscopy.
A spectrum is usually presented
as a graph.
And when you see a graph you
wonder what the axes are.
That's the first thing.
And depending on what point of
view you're taking about
spectroscopy, how you're
understanding it there are
different ways of labeling the
graph.
For example the horizontal and
the vertical coordinates here
in this particular graph are
called wave number and
transmittance, but the meaning
of the axes, with respect to
an experiment, is color, which
light you're talking about
along the horizontal axis, and
vertically, what the light
intensity is.
For example, how much light of a
certain color gets absorbed
by your sample.
Or on the other hand, how much
light doesn't get absorbed and
gets through the sample.
And in fact, that's what's
plotted here is transmitance,
how much light gets through
rather than
how much gets absorbed.
OK, so that's one way of looking
at it, just
experimentally.
But another way is to look at it
in
terms of quantum mechanics.
The horizontal axis is the
molecular-energy gap.
What are the orbitals that are
involved?
How far apart are they in
energy?
What does that have to do with
the frequency of light?
You remember, the rate of this
oscillation back and forth has
to do with the energy difference
between the two
states you're talking about.
And if you're talking about
quantum mechanics, the
vertical axis is how much
overlap you generate.
So when that oxygen had the pi
system on it, in the scarlet
tanager, then you generated a
lot of overlap by mixing the n
with the pi.
But if they were far apart and
the light couldn't induce
overlap, then you didn't get the
fancy color.
You got just the yellow-green
color.
Or you can look at it in terms
of classical mechanics, which
is the way we usually talk about
infrared spectroscopy,
where the horizontal axis is
some actual vibration
frequency of the atoms in a
molecule.
And the vertical axis is how
much handle the light has on
that particular vibration.
For example, if you're vibrating
H2, you don't change
any electronics by doing that.
You don't generated a dipole.
It doesn't interact with light.
But if you vibrate HCl, then you
get a big separation of
positive and negative charge as
you do that, and it does
interact with light.
Light has a good handle on it.
So it's molecular vibration
frequency though--
of course, a molecule of H2 or
HCl is just two atoms. But
normally, the atoms whose bond
you're interested in
vibrating is part of a whole
molecule, and then things get
more complicated. As we will
see.
So infrared spectroscopy uses
light
for a number of purposes.
One is to fingerprint molecules.
And I think you've done this in
lab, to see whether your
spectrum corresponds with a
known spectrum.
Or even if you don't have an
authentic sample, you may have
a table of where functional
groups, even in different
molecules, if it's the same
functional group there maybe
some line that's characteristic.
So you can identify functional
groups and molecules that are
otherwise unknown.
And you can also use it to use
the molecular dynamics that's
involved to study bonding, to
see how strong bonds are,
whether atoms are linked by
springs, for example.
And that's what I'm going to
concentrate on in the lecture,
to use it to understand
molecules.
You you've used it in lab to
identify molecules, to
identify functional groups, but
we're going to use this
last thing to see what it tells
us about how molecules
hold together.
Now, just a quick excursion into
physics or math, to see
what makes vibrations
sinusoidal.
When things vibrate we often
think of them following
a sine wave. But what is the
condition under which they do
actually vibrate according to a
sine wave in time?
So if it's vibrating according
to a sine wave, then the
displacement is some height
times the sin of omega t.
That's how fast it's going up
and down.
That describes the displacement.
So that's the frequency, and t
is the time, and
h is the 1/2 amplitude.
It can go from +1 to -1 as the
sine
goes back and forth.
OK, and that says the velocity,
the change in
position with time, is the
derivative of
that, so the cosine.
And the acceleration is the
second
derivative, so it's that.
And from that then, if the
motion is sinusoidal, as we
said at the beginning, then the
acceleration divided by
the displacement is minus the
frequency squared.
Now, Newton said that
acceleration
is force over mass.
And if things are obeying
Hooke's Law, then the force is
proportional to the
displacement.
And that means we can substitute
in Newton with the
force, -fx, and we get that
a/x is -f/m.
And a/x, we already knew, is
-omega squared.
And that means that the
frequency squared is how
strong the spring is, if it's
Hooke's law, the force constant
divided by the mass.
Or, if we take the square root,
the frequency is the
square root of the force
constant divided by the mass.
So the frequency then is
interesting.
It's constant.
It doesn't depend on the
amplitude of the vibration.
If you have a system that's
obeying Hooke's law, it'll
have the same frequency no
matter what the amplitude.
And that turned out to be very
important.
Incidentally, one of the texts
we're involved in says the
opposite, but it's not true.
OK, so why is that so important?
Hooke's law, Hooke's book, Of
spring in 1678, says
vibrations, if you're obeying
Hooke's Law-- this is where he
set out Hooke's law--
shall be of equal duration
whether they
be greater or less.
Why did he care that the
frequency be always the same
no matter how big the
displacement is?
Can you see why that would make
a difference,
practically?
Ellen?
STUDENT: For clocks.
PROFESSOR: For clocks.
Or more particularly, for
watches, because you know,
about 90 years or 80 years
later, John Harrison made this
marine chronometer, which
allowed to solve the problem
of longitude.
So ships could tell how far they
were from Greenwich by
having accurate time.
And if you look inside this
watch, it looks like that.
There's a spring vibrating like
that.
And it's really, really clever.
I'll show you one other thing
about it.
Notice here, there's a little
rod that goes out here under
the spring.
It's right here.
And it goes out until it makes a
little fork
there around the spring.
Now, that little leaf is
bimetal, so it'll bend with
temperature.
So it changes the length of the
spring as temperature
changes to correct for the
temperature changing the
stiffness of the spring.
Isn't that clever?
OK, that's obviously beside the
point, but it's really a
neat feature of Harrison's H4
chronometer.
So anyhow, when Hooke's law
applies, the frequency is
proportional to the square root
of the force constant
divided by the mass.
So m is the mass.
And this means you could use
this thing
to measure the frequency.
You could measure a mass that
way.
And that's what a quartz crystal
microbalance does.
You can have a quartz crystal
that will vibrate.
I mean, the quartz in my Timex
watch does that, right?
It vibrates as a given-- it
keeps very good time.
So the quartz crystal
microbalance, if you change
its mass by absorbing something
on top of the quartz
crystal, it'll change its
frequency, and
you can measure it.
In fact, it's so sensitive, that
if you coat it with
platinum, and then let ethylene
in to absorb on the
platinum, it'll get heavier and
the
frequency will slow down.
But if you then admit hydrogen,
the platinum
catalyzes the reaction and the
ethane goes off, and you can
measure that change of one
monolayer of ethylene on
platinum by using a quartz
crystal microbalance.
That's just a neat feature.
So if we're talking not about
what's going on the surface
of a quartz crystal, but about
molecules vibrating, then, for
atoms, the force constant should
be how
stiff the bond is.
A single bond should be easier
to stretch than a double bond,
than a triple bond.
But are they really that?
Is the force constant really
proportional to 1, 2, 3?
Is a double bond twice as strong
as a single bond, for
this purpose of how rapidly
things vibrate?
Or a triple bond three times as
strong?
So this is something we can
check by using infrared
spectroscopy.
Now, with respect to the mass,
things get more complicated,
because it's not just one atom
that's moving.
Usually it would be at least two
atoms that are moving.
And then what do you use for the
mass?
It turns out, that in a
diatomic, what you use is
called the reduced mass.
It's the product of the two
masses divided by their sum.
And we don't need to go into why
that is.
But what that means is that that
effective mass--
use the Greek mu, the Greek m,
mu instead of m--
that's dominated by the smaller
mass.
Because suppose m2 is
really small.
Then the denominator, for
practical purposes, is m1.
m2 has nothing to do with it.
But the m1 in the denominator
then cancels out the m1 in the
numerator, and all you
have is m2.
So it's the smaller thing that
counts.
You'd usually think it would be
the larger thing.
OK, so let's look at what that
would be.
For example, for hydrogen and
carbon that we're vibrating,
it would be 1 x 12/(1+12).
Almost 1, right?
The 12's almost cancel.
If it's carbon-carbon then it's
going to be
1/2 of carbon 6.
If it's carbon-oxygen it's going
to be 6.9.
If it's carbon-chlorine it's
8.9.
So even when it gets much
heavier, it doesn't make much
difference.
It's mostly pretty much like
other carbon bonds.
So what that means is that bonds
involving hydrogen have
really, really different
frequencies from those
involving not hydrogen, because
it's so much lighter.
1 to 6 here, or more.
So it stands apart, the mass of
hydrogen.
Now, how about the bonds then?
So C-H then, is proportional to
the square root of a single
bond over 0.9, that's
reduced mass.
And that turns out to be around
3000 wave numbers, or
10 to the 14th Hz.
So that's how fast C-H bonds
vibrate.
A C-O bond has a heavier mass,
6.9 versus 0.9.
If it's a single bond, that's
going to be about 1100 wave
numbers, or 3 x 10 to the 13th
Hz.
And that, remember, is that what
you put in front in
Eyring
to get a rate, it's 10 to the
13th, times that equilibrium
constant to the transition
state.
That's because of this.
That's how fast atoms like
carbon and oxygen vibrate.
OK, so a C double bond, though,
if a double bond is
twice as high as a single bond,
should be 2, the square
root of 2/6.9, and that's about
1500.
And that's about right.
And a triple bond is higher
still, with a 3 for the force
constant, about 1900.
So you can see that if you have
a spectrum, where 3000 is
on the left, and 1000 is toward
the right, then you're
going to have hydrogens up here,
hydrogens stretching
about 3000, and then you're
going to get triple bonds,
double bonds, single bonds
involving
other atoms, not hydrogen.
But it's not that simple,
because a single atom is
connected, not to just one other
atom, but others, and
they couple with each other.
So this, our study of coupled
oscillators is going to
illustrate several things.
The complexity of what's really
involved in vibration,
and why physical chemists
thought at the beginning that
it was going to be impossible to
interpret anything in IR
spectroscopy.
And then the idea of normal mode
analysis, and what a
normal mode is, and phase of
mixing, and the possibility of
things being independent, so you
can think about a functional
group having a particular thing,
not being all mixed up
with others.
So for this purpose we're going
to look at some
oscillators, at this particular
thing here.
Let's see if I can get this, get
the lights I need here.
OK, so here are some things
that'll oscillate.
So if I take this, it vibrates
at a certain frequency.
It's a spring that's being bent
back and forth, so it's
Hooke's law.
And that's what I've shown here.
It's a simple oscillator.
I bend it.
I let it go.
It flops back and forth at a
given rate.
And we know what that rate's
going to be.
The square of the frequency is
going to be whatever the force
constant-- how stiff the spring
is--
divided by the mass of that
thing up on top, and of the
spring itself, of course.
OK, that's fine.
Now, suppose we put a spring in
there as well.
But let me hold this one fixed,
or hold this one fixed.
And I'm going to do this then.
Now, can you tell me whether
that vibration should be
faster or slower than it was
when I didn't
have the spring there?
What's the difference?
The difference is that now we
have a stronger spring.
Everybody see that?
Because we've added this spring
to however hard it is
to bend that.
So it's going to be a higher
frequency.
And we could time it, and figure
it out.
We don't have time to do that,
but it's faster.
If it's coupled to a frozen
partner like that--
I'm holding the partner--
then I let it go and it
stretches back and forth, and
it has a stronger spring.
It's the main spring plus this
little one, plus s.
We could couple that in, so
that's easy enough.
Now we're going to look at it
when I'm not holding it.
It's going to be in-phase
coupling.
So they're going to be moving
the same direction.
So I move them both out here,
and I let them go, and they go
back and forth.
Now, what should that frequency
be?
Is this spring being stretched?
No, so it's just as it was
originally.
So if we do this and do that,
and let go, then it goes back
and forth, not stretching the
spring.
Or if you look at the thing as a
whole, there are two weights
and two springs being bent, so
it's 2f/2m, but it's the same
as we started with.
Now, the interesting one is to
do out-of-phase coupling,
where they don't go in parallel
but antiparallel to
one another.
Now, what about this situation
here now?
Is that spring being stretched?
In fact, it's being stretched
twice as much as it was
before, because the middle is
staying in place, and both
things are stretching it.
So if we do that, if we do this
one.
Out-of-phase coupling--
and notice that the center stays
fixed--
now as it does that, we have a
much stronger spring.
It's 2s in the middle now.
I'm sorry you can't see this
very well, but you can look at
what we review.
So it's 2s in the middle, so
now frequency is higher.
Now, so when the two were
isolated from one another,
that is, when we held one fixed
and just looked at one
vibrate, all we had was that
little extra spring in the
middle, then they would both
vibrate at the
same frequency, isolated.
Can you see it there?
I think you can.
Actually, let me just put it on
the other screen and then
you'll be able to see it.
Yeah, OK, good.
But once we let them both move
and they couple their motion,
then there's an out-of-phase and
an in-phase. One is higher
frequency. One doesn't stretch
the spring, the other
stretches it twice as much.
Does this remind you of anything
you've seen before?
That diagram?
It's the same thing as orbitals
mixing, to give an
in-phase and an out-of-phase.
The math is just the same.
So this is called, either of
these, the in-phase or the
out-of-phase, is called a normal
mode.
The meaning of it is that in
that pattern of vibration, all
the atoms are oscillating at the
same
frequency in a normal mode.
It's a lower frequency here and
a higher frequency here,
but both atoms are moving in
phase with one another, you
know, at the same oscillation
frequency.
Now we're going to do another
one, in which--
so they move back and forth at
the same amplitude, the same
frequency, or when they started
the same.
So that's out-of-phase and this
one was in-phase.
Now, notice that if I added
those two together, those two
displacements, those two
vibration patterns, I would
get something where one moved
and the other didn't.
So I could do that.
And what I'm saying is, that
that is the sum of the
in-phase motion and the
out-of-phase motion.
So if I sum them, I get this one
to move and these cancel.
So when I let go now, I'm
actually exciting two normal
modes, the in-phase and the
out-of-phase.
Does everybody see what I'm
doing?
Because what I've done here is
the sum of the two of them.
So now when I let go, something
neat happens.
STUDENT: That is cool.
PROFESSOR: So what's happening?
STUDENTS: murmurs.
PROFESSOR: It's going back and
forth
between one vibrating and the
other vibrating.
Why?
Because those two modes have
different frequencies, and
they get in step and then out of
step with one another, and
when they're in step with one
another, this one is moving,
that's how we started it. And
not this one, and when it's
one minus the other it's this.
And because they have different
frequencies, they're
cycling in and out of phase with
one another.
I think that's just so
wonderful.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's exactly what we were
looking at at the beginning,
where things went in and out of
phase with one another,
where it was 1s going to 2p.
What we started, when we moved
just one of them and held the
other one fixed, was a
superposition of two normal
modes of different frequency.
And then the vibration beats in
and out of phase.
So now, what happens, if one of
them's heavy and the other
one's-- so then you can't talk
about just one of them
vibrating. When they're coupled
this way--
but suppose I made one of them
heavier than the other, so it
vibrates normally at a very
different frequency.
If I can get this on there...
And now let me move this one.
Let me move this one and not
this one.
And what should happen-- what we
saw before was the
vibration goes from there, to
there, to there, to there--
but now look what happens.
I actually moved that one a
little bit at the beginning.
This one's not moving nearly as
much as that one is.
This one keeps moving.
Remember, the other one went
dead still and then the other
one and then the other.
Now it's staying localized
mostly.
And if I did this one, it stays
mostly here. Very little
comes over there.
So if the two things have very
different frequencies, then
they don't couple very much.
They stay mostly independent, if
they have different
independent... different
individual frequencies.
And that's exactly like the wave
functions mixing.
If we have one that's low energy
and one that's high
frequency, and we couple them,
you'll get one that's in phase
and one that's out of phase, but
they won't be very
different from one another.
It's an exact analogue of the
energy-match and overlap
thing, where the energy-match is
now how different the
frequencies are, or the
energy-mismatch, and the overlap
is how strong this spring is
between them.
So if I make the spring really
strong, then even though they
have different frequencies,
they'll be more
mixed with one another.
Now this, it's weird, but this
one is moving more.
But if I make it very weak
coupling, like that, then they
really stay independent of one
another.
So it's a really neat physical
demonstration of what we saw
last semester.
OK, that's enough of that for
now.
If I can get this off.
So you can come play with that
afterwards if you want to.
So vibration remains localized
when the coupling is weak,
compared to the energy mismatch.
These illustrate that.
So if you have a general
molecule that has N atoms in
it, there are 3N independent
geometric parameters, x, y,
and z for all the N atoms. But
it takes three numbers to say
where the center of the molecule
is.
And it takes another three
numbers to tell how much you
rotated around this axis, how
much you rotated around this
axis, how much you rotated
around this axis, so that's
three more numbers to fix the
orientation.
So you have 3N-6 coordinates
that involve
internal vibration.
But it's not just two atoms that
are vibrating, it's the
whole set of atoms that are
vibrating.
And in a normal mode, they all
vibrate at the same frequency.
But there are going to be 3N-6
normal modes, and this
is where physical chemists threw
up their hands, and
said, it's just so complicated
how all these springs are
interacting with each other,
that we're never going to
understand it.
So forget trying to interpret.
OK for a fingerprint, but forget
trying to interpret it.
So it sounds hopelessly complex,
though it's good for
a fingerprint.
But remember, to get mixing, you
have to have frequency
match and some coupling
mechanism.
So if you have some of these
bonds that vibrate without
similar frequencies to anything
in the neighborhood,
or not coupled to things in the
neighborhood, then they'll
appear independently, and you
can hope to identify a
particular functional group.
So if they're isolated, they're
independent, but if
they're coupled, then you see
complication.
So it's again this question of
energy-match and overlap.
Now let's look at the butane,
C4H10 .
It's got 42 degrees of freedom,
42 of these, minus
the 3 translations and the 3
rotations, so there are 36
vibrations, 36 normal modes that
are involved.
If you just had the four
carbons, there'd be three
stretches, two bends and a
twist, the
torsion around the middle.
With 10 C-H's, you have 10
stretches,
and 20 bends or twists.
But it's not that simple,
because they get mixed up,
according to frequency-match and
coupling, into 36
complicated normal modes.
Let's see if we can understand
anything about
these normal modes.
So here's a spectrum of a
hydrocarbon, it's C8H18.
You've seen a spectrum like
this, I bet, in lab.
Let's see if we can understand
what any of the peaks are.
First notice, that there are
peaks at the far left, around
3000, and the others are all
1500 or below.
What do you think's up at the
top, high frequencies?
STUDENTS: C-H
PROFESSOR: C-H's, right.
Because the H is so light.
OK, so there are 72 normal modes
here, but not all of
them are IR active with this
C8H18.
So let's look at that particular
peak there.
There are actually several there
but, anyhow,
one of them is this.
So there we have a molecule and
here we distort it.
Now, tell me what's happening in
the distortion?
What's mostly changing?
STUDENTS: C-H bonds.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, its C-H bonds
are stretching
and shrinking, right?
And notice the way they're doing
it.
Focus on the two central CH2s.
The hydrogens are moving up and
down, up and down.
So the charge is moving up and
So that's going to interact then
with light, with an
electric field of light that's
pointing in that way.
So light can help push those
four central H's up and down.
That particular vibration, that
particular normal mode,
interacts with light, and you
get absorption of light at
that position.
When it's up, it pushes it one
way.
When the field is down, it
pushes it the other way, and
we interact with light.
So that's a C-H stretch.
Now, how about this one?
Here we have-- or one of the
peaks under there at least--
here it's this and then that.
What's happening now?
What bonds are changing?
What kinds of bonds?
Is that C-C or C-H?
STUDENTS: C-H
PROFESSOR: It's C-H. And notice
how
they're doing.
They're all going in or out
together.
So that's going to do it.
What direction of the light's
electric
vector will excite this?
It's going to be perpendicular
to the screen, to push them
all in, all out.
So it's a different polarization
of the light
that's going to do this one.
It's going to be the light that
goes that way
or goes that way.
Now there are a lot of others
that we won't go into.
One of them is this.
Look at this now.
What's happening now?
Again, we're stretching C-H
bonds.
How strongly is this going to
interact with light?
Notice, for every H that goes
one way, there's another H that
goes exactly the opposite way,
so those cancel out and
there's no interaction with
light.
So that sort of breathing, where
they're all going out
and in at the same time doesn't
interact.
You don't see that in the IR.
So in fact, half of the 10 C-H
stretching normal modes have
no handle on them.
They don't change the dipole
moment.
So they don't absorb light.
And that's where we're going to
have to stop now and go on
to the other peaks next time.